bowser's fury the new mode included with
the switch we release of super mario 3d
world
combines the gameplay of super mario 3d
world and super mario odyssey into a
brand new open world mario title
the game may seem daunting at first but
fear not fellow explorers as i have some
tips you may find useful before starting
your adventure on lake labcat
if you'd like to see more super mario 3d
world plus bowser's fury content then
consider subscribing and let us know in
the comments what you'd like to see
anyways as a certain italian plumber
would say let's go
looking for more shines leave an area
and come back every major island has
five shines to collect
and once you get one you might not know
where to start searching for the others
you might even look all around the
island and not find another shine but if
you leave an island's proximity and then
come back it should refresh the island
and spawn a new shine as well as give
you a new shine objective
normally this amounts to walking out of
the cat gate and walking back in
but if that doesn't work then you can
tell if you're outside of the island's
proximity if the music changes since
each island has a tune whew
this also applies to cat shine split
into five pieces as some islands expand
and change the more shines you get
and some of those pieces are hiding in
future versions of the island
don't forget to get the power-ups on the
towers every time you collect the shine
you'll get a little scene where the
shine flies up to the tower and the
tower begins to shine
what you might not know is that the top
of the tower has a little sparkly area
you could ground pound to get a power-up
the nice thing about bowser's fury is
that you could bank power-ups
five of each so it's not like 3d world
where you only get one you have equipped
and a backup
each time you get a shine the tower
lights up again and you can get another
power-up
but they do not stack for example if you
neglect a ground pound the top of the
tower until you've gotten 4 of the 5
shines then you'll only get 1 power up
once you get all 5 cat shines a flag
will sprout on top of the tower and you
won't be able to get any power ups
power ups are abundant so you don't
really have to worry about this but it's
nice to have the cards stacked in your
favor early on not ready to fight fury
bowser
no problem every couple of minutes fury
bowser decides to rear his ugly head
and you may not want to fight him just
yet if you've collected the necessary
amount of shines to do so
good news is you don't have to to make
fury bowser go away you can collect any
shine on the island or after a while he
just decides to leave anyways
there really isn't a downside either way
fighting and defeating fury bowser opens
more areas on the island but waiting
collecting more shines each time he
appears can deplete his health to make
the battle ahead a little easier
you can't deplete his health all the way
before confronting him though so be
careful not to abuse this or he'll get
even more furious
having trouble fighting fury bowser look
for the bells you might notice during
the fury bowser fight that you no longer
have access to your item bank
and yes you can get hit and go back to
regular mario and even little mario just
giant variants of those two so what can
you do it might be hard to spot but if
you go back to any of the cat bell
locations they've now turned into bells
you can use to go back
into super saiyan cat mario form vegeta
what does a scouter say about his power
level
it's over 9000 what nine
thousand they don't always respawn
immediately but they do respawn so don't
worry if you lose the cat suit again
the bowser amiibo is actually helpful
amiibo are pretty hit or miss when it
comes to functionality within games even
if the figurines are usually cool
but surprisingly the bowser amiibo is
helpful in bowser's fury
let me break it down every island has
these steel boxes with bowser's face on
them
how do you break them fury bowser has to
blow fire on them when he's after you
and when they break it reveals a shine
inside
now without the amiibo you can approach
this one of two ways you could stand
there and wait for fury bowser to show
up or you can head straight there as the
rain starts to fall and hope you get
there in time
what the bowser amiibo does is
automatically spawn fury bowser
yes you heard that right so now you can
get to the boxes
tap the amiibo have fury bowser open the
boxes then get the shine and have fury
bowser go away
it's true that the amiibo only works
once per shine but if you summon fury
bowser get him to open the boxes and
then collect the shine that counts as
one so you can go from location to
location and do this one after another
if you wanted
no waiting for maximum efficiency
don't forget about bowser jr bowser jr
is a very set it and forget it character
if you're playing single player
you can choose to have him help a little
a lot or not at all this amounts to
bowser jr grabbing coins or hitting
enemies off to the side so he's pretty
easy to forget
but if you ever come across these little
question marks on the wall you have to
hit
r then use the gyro to send bowser jr to
paint over them
sometimes it reveals just a power up but
sometimes it's a gold pipe that leads to
a bunch of coins
admittedly coins aren't super useful in
this game get a hundred and you get
another power up and if you die then you
lose 50 coins which is similar to the
system in super mario odyssey
but hey the more power-ups the better
right sometimes 100 coins will even lead
to a superstar
they ask you how you are you just have
to say that you're fine when you're not
really fine but you just can't get into
it because they would never understand
you can actually play bowser's fury with
two players
and player two controls bowser jr so if
that's you then you could throw this tip
right out the window while making sure
your player two isn't screwing around
making your life more difficult don't
worry about dying
jumping off an earlier point i just
mentioned dying in this game is not a
big deal
there are no lives to collect and you
can die as many times as you want the
system works exactly like odyssey
you die and you lose coins you only lose
50 coins at a time so thankfully if
you're working towards a new power-up
you won't lose everything
but otherwise there's no penalty which
gives you the freedom to explore the
world and experiment with things
also don't worry about getting all the
shines before the end if you're like me
you probably want to get all the shines
before heading into the final battle but
you also might have noticed that the
game doesn't clue you into where the
remaining shines are
or how many are left fear not my fellow
completionists once you do finish the
final battle bowser jr will let you know
how many are left
and where the rest are on the map there
are also some shines that can only
become accessible once you finish the
final
fight so it's impossible to get
everything beforehand anyways that's not
to say you should only get the necessary
amount and move on there are some
benefits to having extra cat shines in
the bank
but maybe you don't save the hardest
ones for last as you progress through
the game fury bowser will show up
a little more frequently than before for
example if you have 48 shines but the
gigabyte unlocks at 50 then fury bowser
will show up even more than normal
but even if you do have extra shines
fury bowser will still show up a little
more frequently than before as the game
progresses and you unlock more islands
for this reason i recommend not saving
some of the trickier ones for last as it
can become an even bigger challenge
ones that require precise platforming
while also avoiding fury bowser's fiery
blast can be a bit of a headache
unless you're into that sort of thing
and that my friends is where the tips
come to an end bowser's fury is a
relatively short journey and i hope
these tips help you along the way
if you like this video then consider
clicking the like button and if you have
any further questions about bowser's
fury or even super mario 3d world then
feel free to drop a comment below and
i'll try to respond as best as i can
thanks so much for watching and stay
tuned to gamespot for all the latest on
super mario 3d world plus bowser's fury
[Applause]
[Music]
you